etiopía deja por fuera a siete
observadores internacionales en su
momento más crítico el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores del país anunció la
expulsión de los altos funcionarios de
naciones unidas entre los que se
encuentra el director de la agencia para
la infancia unicef y el jefe de asuntos
humanitarios el ministerio de exteriores
declara persona non grata a siete
personas que han estado trabajando para
algunas agencias humanitarias de la onu
en etiopía por inmiscuirse en asuntos
internos del país deben salir dentro de
las próximas 72 horas las expulsiones
tuvieron lugar a tan sólo dos días de
que el jefe para la ayuda humanitaria
advirtiera que cientos de miles de
personas están al borde de la hambruna
debido a un bloqueo del gobierno que
impide la llegada de ayudas a la región
del tigray en etiopía
the ring life safe en etiopía la onu
está proporcionando ayuda para salvar
vidas incluidos alimentos medicinas agua
y suministros de saneamiento a personas
que lo necesitan desesperadamente en
etiopía the wind es work tengo plena
confianza en el personal de la onu que
está en etiopía haciendo este trabajo
eeuu condenó la acción y llamó al
consejo de seguridad de la onu a
esclarecer lo que sucede en el interior
del país el gobierno de eeuu condena en
los términos más enérgicos la acción sin
precedentes del gobierno de etiopía para
expulsar a los líderes de todas las
organizaciones de naciones unidas-
involucradas en operaciones humanitarias
en curso el conflicto en el tigra y
escaló desde noviembre de 2020 cuando el
gobierno lanzó un operativo contra el
frente popular de liberación del tigray
en represalia por un ataque a una base
militar pese a un cese al fuego desde
finales de junio miles de personas han
muerto y dos millones se han visto
desplazadas muchas otras están atrapadas
sin suministros básicos